- Shut the front door, man. Oh my gosh.
- My name is Alissa.
I am actually a recent graduate
from veterinary school.
- I'm Wenjay Sung. I am
a foot and ankle surgeon.
- My name is Courtney Campbell.
I'm a veterinarian that specializes
in surgery in Santa Barbara.
- I haven't played "Operation" probably
since the early 80's.
- I don't remember if I ever
played. I know the game.
- I've never played"
Operation" so I have no idea
how this is gonna go.
- I didn't come here to make friends.
You know the game's not
called "Operation Friends."
- When you're doing surgery
you need to be confident,
you need to go for it,
and if you bump something
along the way, you fix your mistakes.
- I am very competitive.
I am going to destroy everybody else.
Do you guys know how to
play this game actually?
- No.
- One thing you don't want to
do in surgery is just wing it.
- Apparently this is Sam.
- [Courtney] Okay, hi Sam.
Hello.
Repair Sam's heart and charge your fee.
He'll thank you most wholeheartedly.
I just made that
infinitely more difficult.
- Exactly.
- You have to have a steady hand.
- [Courtney] Butterflies in stomach.
- I think this game is
actually impossible. Or not.
- Alright.
- Well done.
Student loans.
- Yes, student loans.
- This goes to salary,
mate. Thank you very much.
- So now we've got the wishbone.
- [Alissa] So when we played this as a kid
this is how I learned anatomy.
- So the wishbone's
connected to the thighbone.
Amazing. Nice job.
- Can I get knuckles on it?
- [Alissa] Water on the knee.
- She's on the board.
[crosstalk]
- I want to thank my fellow surgeons.
- [Courtney] Funny bone.
There's nothing funny about this.
- [Wenjay] I wish I didn't
like you guys so much,
but your skills aren't that
great, so it's alright.
- [Courtney] Oh man,
wow, you just went there.
(buzzer)
(inaudible)
- So close.
- [Courtney] So close.
Except it wasn't.
- Oh my goodness, it's just getting easier
and easier for you.
- [Alissa] Too much ice
cream froze Sam's brain.
- I believe that's facial
nerve apraxia there.
- You just nerded out right there.
- I couldn't help it, I couldn't help it.
- Oh wow.
- Six hundred dollars, please.
- Wow.
- [Wenjay] Stretch your
leg from peg to peg
and you will heal Sam's aching leg.
This is actually really hard.
(buzzer)
- Oh.
- I've been working up
toward this my entire life.
(buzzer)
That was intense.
- It screamed at you this time.
(buzzer)
- [Wenjay] Oh.
- Everybody's holding their breath.
- Yes.
- [Alissa] Oh.
Money pours from the ceiling.
Nice job. Bang your
fists on that. Nice job.
- Let's count the money. Like
all good doctors, we gotta.
- That's what we do at
the end of the day, right?
(cheers)
- How did you get 2,800 dollars?
- I'm really good.
- Formidable opponents, but
I think one of them cheated.
She was born with slender fingers.
And the other one cheated because I think
he's been practicing all week.
- That was a really stupid game.
- Well this was a great game.
I would highly recommend this
to adults, not to children.
Children should never play
this. Adults get the benefit.
- If kids want to be
surgeons, just play Xbox.
- Look at his face.
[Alissa] He's horrified.
- He is horrified.
- [Alissa] I think he's
mainly horrified though,
because he's not under anesthesia.